bought and paid for that's the focus of
tonight's angle
now every now and then a young person
will pose a question that exposes the
intellectual laziness and arrogance of
an adult used to coasting on old
connections
such was the case recently at the
university of chicago which hosted an
event called disinformation and the
erosion of democracy
watch how a college freshman gets
panelist writer ann applebaum to reveal
her willingness to cover up for the
bidens
so in 2020 you wrote those who live
outside the fox news bubble do not of
course need to learn any of this stuff
about hunter biden referring to his
laptop of curse
a poll later after that found that if
voters knew about the content of the
laptop sixteen percent of joe biden
voters would have acted differently do
you think the media acted
inappropriately when they instantly
dismissed uh hunter biden's laptop as
russian disinformation my problem with
hunter biden's laptop is i think totally
irrelevant i mean it's not whether it's
disinformation or i mean i don't think
the
hunter biden's um
business relationships have anything to
do with who should be president of the
united states so
i didn't i don't find it to be
interesting
of course she doesn't think it's
irrelevant
she's just another self-appointed elite
who's far more worried about threats to
europe than threats to the united states
and not to be outdone by a fellow never
trumper a former conservative jonah
goldberg
says that even if big tech and the media
colluded to censor the hunter biden
story it was no big deal
they now think that if only the media
had told us about the laptop at the time
as the kid yesterday was suggesting
which i don't buy his ex you know theory
that trump would have won you know but
for the censoring of the new york post
trump would have won
and it's i think it's a preposterous
counterfactual
and to think that he once wrote a book
called liberal fascism i wonder what he
thinks of that book today
now goldberg conveniently fails to
mention the polls showing 16 percent of
biden voters
would not have voted for him had they
known about the true hunter biden story
the only good thing in fact that came
out of this conference were the young
journalists who had the courage to call
out the media's glaring hypocrisy
the folks on stage are all friends with
high flyers in big tech and on wall
street and who make billions in china
and they don't want our government to do
anything to upset their cash flows
they're bought and paid for
now china plays a
leadership position for the world in
in
many different areas china the whole
region
is a very very exciting place
what a dweeb now it's no wonder that the
defense industry and the journalists who
nurse at the ccp's bosom save their
hawkishness for russia or maybe the
middle east
they won't advocate for the u.s
decoupling from china even as they
acknowledge the ongoing threat that
china poses
there is just no country
that presents a broader threat
to our ideas
our innovation
and our economic security than china
okay he's right so why aren't they
laying out a strategy to counter this
where's the biden administration's
promised pivot to asia
well don't hold your breath
general milly testified that the ukraine
conflict will be unfolding for years
meanwhile as we blow through untold
billions it means to eastern europe
china is working overtime to marginalize
and ultimately eclipse the united states
militarily and economically
now when word got out that nancy pelosi
was considering an official visit to
taiwan
china brazenly warned her off
if house speaker pelosi visits taiwan
it will seriously violate the one china
principle
and seriously impact the political
foundation
of u.s china relations
china is firmly opposed to this
now china would never dare take that
threatening a posture under trump we
know they would not
but with biden
they feel like they have all the
leverage and basically they do
and years ago with hunter biden they saw
an easy target who better than a
nerdwell son of a sitting vice president
then
my computer
had taken tons of like
um like just left that like that came on
he would always put again like pascal
you know
it was like
crazy
and
somebody stole it
and he
did like this kind of pretend search
i think he's the one who built my
computer
i think the three of the three guys
that were like little like
group
i didn't do that
like
i took them everywhere
it was an easy setup to get some ccp
connected company to put him on the
payroll and hope that some of that money
would ultimately trickle down to a
principal aka the big guy joe biden
now could this explain at least
partially why biden has still not
unveiled a sensible china strategy
why he's not held china accountable at
all for its destruction of the evidence
at the wuhan lab
house republicans are claiming that they
have
uh significant circumstantial evidence
that covet 19 originated in a lab has
the white house seen any circumstantial
evidence that it did not
originate in a lab
well i think first i would caution you
against disproving a negative there
which is never the responsible approach
in our view whenever when it comes to
getting to the bottom of the root causes
of a pandemic that has killed hundreds
of thousands of people in the united
states
she should put out a best of lies album
that would be a big hit
now we're learning more every day about
what was on that laptop and according to
whistleblower jack maxey who
gained access to the hard drive there's
a lot more where that came from here's
what he told dailymail.com
and ultimately we found
450 gigabytes
of what hunter thought was erased
material
amongst those things were 80 000 images
and videos now since then we found
thousands and thousands of pdfs we
didn't know about
we believe that we've been able to
scrape all the attachments
we keep finding more and more things
and so that became quite horrifying
horrifying well nothing to see here it's
only our most dangerous adversary
getting money to the son of a man
who was helping run our china policy at
the time
now we know biden is capable of
condemning foreign assaults against
human liberty when he wants to
we're going to keep raising the economic
cost and ratchet up the pain for putin
and further increase russia's economic
isolation
but on president xi's relentless assault
on human rights in china barely a peep
and why aren't we using our leverage to
actively deter him from continuing to
support russia
i had a a very straightforward
conversation with
she uh
made it clear to him i made no threats
but it made it clear to him
that make sure he understood the
consequences of him helping russia
wow i bet that really scared him boss
the plain truth is without xi's
financial backing
russia wouldn't be able to wage a war in
ukraine
yet something is holding biden back from
forcefully warning china
not to fund russia's brutal rampage
what could that something be does the
media even care the us attorney in
delaware currently is investigating
hunter's laptop maybe he'll shed some
light on this
how much did hunter rake in from the
fake work he did for the chinese energy
company and what promises explicit or
implicit did he have to make to seal the
deal and did some of that cash end up
benefiting his father in some way
now contrary to what ms applebaum
contended these questions are very
relevant
with the exception of the washington
post which urged a media reckoning over
their 2020 bearing of the hunter bite in
the laptop story most of the press
simply don't care
no one really on the left is willing to
take the steps to isolate china
even as the ccp is the invisible hand
that helps fund russian aggression in
ukraine
the reason china doesn't take biden
seriously
is because they think of him as someone
who is on their payroll
if hunter biden were being paid off by
let's say putin-controlled businesses
everyone at the university of chicago
forum would care and care a lot
if the fact is
they just don't believe that getting
paid off by the ccp is that that big of
a deal
think of it this way
january 6
is a threat to democracy worthy of a
two-year-long investigation
but china's vision to dominate the globe
their shocking human rights abuses and
financial payoff to the biden family
isn't
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else